hey youtubers it's Charlie so Gotham is
back there's gonna be my episode 1 video
and if you watch Gotham 1 you could
think of that as like Batman year one
think of season two is like the long
Halloween if you didn't read the long
Halloween that's like one of the best
Batman stories of all time so you need
to check it out but it's about Batman
villains becoming full-fledged
supervillains Gotham season 2 as they've
been pitching is the rise of the
villains now they're not gonna be doing
a comic book story like they're not
doing the story of long Halloween from
the comics but I like the way that they
line up the matically and by the way the
guy that wrote the long Halloween Jeff
lobe he's actually running Marvel
television right now which i think is
kind of funny he used to write DC Comics
for a lot of time before he went to
Marvel so just careful for spoilers from
the episode if you haven't seen it yet
I'm gonna do top 5 moments and that'll
explain who some of the new comic book
characters we met are there were a
couple of them there are a bunch of
bigger ones that are coming later
starting with number 5 it's a perfect
day in Gotham so the funny thing is is
if you just watch The Walking Dead video
that I just posted fear The Walking Dead
episode 4 also open with that exact same
song which is just hilarious
AMC Fox 2 completely different networks
Bruce is still trying to get into that
secret door the demoted Gordon puts on
his street cop uniform and heads out to
work and Barbara waltzes into Arkham
like she's checking into the happiness
hotel from the Muppets seriously when
all the villains turned around and
looked at her all I could think about
was that scene from the great Muppet
Caper and that kind of ridiculous energy
is gonna be really important just add
that to your bookmarks for whenever I
talk about the Riddler in a second on to
number four meet theo galavan new
super-criminal and gotham very well
connected to the upper crust and the
mayor's office
he gives arden mysterious blue potion
who takes it and then goes on a rampage
I like the way they twisted it and made
it funny like oh I thought this was
supposed to make me invincible when
clearly Theo just wanted him to get
locked up in Arkham so that his sister
tigress could get all the criminals out
now Theo this character that he's
playing is not a comic book character
there are a lot of people that are
wondering if that's just a false name
and he might secretly be Rachele ghoul I
don't think that's the case because
arrow just did that character and Gotham
wouldn't do their version like right
after that I don't think that Warner
Brothers would allow that I don't think
that Theo is a secret identity for
anyone else I think that's who his
characters gonna be for the rest of the
season and
as I mentioned his sister Tabitha gala
fan here was announced as tigress she's
one of the new comic book characters now
there have been different versions of
tigress that have shown up in the
animated movies there was one on Young
Justice for a little while
there's actually three versions of the
character in the comics one was just an
enemy for Satara she didn't have a name
the second version was Paula Brooks in
the next version was artemis croc now
what the TV show has done I think is
take the Artemis croc Tigris and just
give that persona to the Tabitha
character you could argue which version
of tiger if she's most liked I think
we'll have to wait till the end of the
season but largely I think this is gonna
be the show's interpretation of that
character they're not gonna give her a
storyline from tigress in the comics or
anything like that on to number three
sometimes the wrong thing is the right
thing so we start to see a darker
version of Bruce Wayne like just getting
a little bit closer to that Batman
persona like the adult Bruce Wayne who
is like the most untrusting character in
the DC Universe
I wouldn't call him paranoid Batman's
kind of paranoid but he doesn't even
trust the rest of the Justice League and
they're his friends so Gordon of course
having a symmetrical arc to the Bruce
Wayne character just goes dark which i
think is great for Ben McKenzie too I
think the character is gonna be a lot
more fun to watch with some edge on him
and once we meet Michael Chiklis
character he'll seem tame by comparison
Michael Chiklis is gonna be beating the
[ __ ] out of a bunch of people just wait
till he shows up give me all of your
clobberin time jokes
so if course gordon makes a deal with
the devil and after some hemming and
hawing he goes to get penguins money and
ends up killing the mobster that he was
trying to get the money from just like
the worst possible scenario we can't
leave town Leslie I did a bad thing
speaking of which number two Barbara's
phone call this is one of my favorite
parts of the episode not the first part
just the second part I hope you die
screaming [ __ ] their scenes are gonna
be so much fun I feel like when they try
to be serious about stuff like that
that's when it's not fun like when they
just embrace the craziness and just like
okay let's make this as ridiculous as
possible that's when it's fun and just
to connect that to what's going on with
the Riddler this year so we saw him
earlier in the episode it seems like he
has split personalities and that's how
his Riddler persona is gonna emerge but
this is actually what the actor said
this thing this this other guy we're
seeing here in the mirror not going away
anytime soon and I was really relieved
when he said that this is not going to
be the Riddler like
this alternate persona the Riddler
himself doesn't have an alternate
personality like he just is the way he
is so we're gonna have to wait and see
where this alternate personality thing
goes but I think they're just using it
as a way of thematically showing that
all the characters craziness is just
getting turned way way up like someone
has the crazy knob and they're just
cranking it till 11:00 and finally out
of my number one WTF moment all of
Gotham is burdened with glorious purpose
all the heroes all the villains gonna be
way more hardcore this year that means
way crazier villains and way darker
heroes which is where we get to Gotham's
version of long Halloween feel here puts
together his super villain team bromance
Ionis ends up being the red shirt now
you can think of him as black mask but
he's just listed as the mask in the
credits technically I think it's his son
in the comics that ends up being the
true black mask this big guy that
Barbara gets to protect her he's a mig
doula from the comics and this character
here is named Robert Greenwood but I
don't think he's summer from the comics
he's supposed to be a cannibal though so
he'll be like one of the crazier people
in this crew I didn't really mention
Jerome but you guys know all about
Jerome you met him last year he's kind
of like the show's version of the Joker
just one iteration of the Joker maybe
not the true Joker but the first one
that they're going with someone else
could come along later and take the
mantle one of the really high moment
that I did mention is when zazz and
penguin go to the commissioners house to
get him out of the way zaz holds that
guards head up and just plays with a
little I laughed so hard yes it is
ridiculous but it's supposed to be
ridiculous like it's very self-aware
that's being silly so just think about
the dichotomy between the cop drama
elements of the show in like the crazy
villain elements like whenever the
villains are on screen they get their
own special music that just sounds kind
of funny and weird entering the Gordon
cop drama stuff it just sounds a little
bit more normal so as things continue to
spiral out of control what I'm really
interested to see is if some of the
normal characters or you know the
characters you could consider as being
normal start getting crazy music in
their scenes like Bruce here for
instance when he tried to smash that
panel it was almost like he started to
go crazy I don't I don't think they went
far enough like Alfred made the joke
about building the bomb I was kind of
hoping that Bruce would start yanking it
his hair like oh really really crazy
it's just a way for the show to tell you
that all the characters are losing their
minds the heroes and the villains like
that's gonna be a big thing this season
here's the big question for you guys how
do you feel about the two separate tones
of this show like it's a show with dual
identities you have the cop drama then
you have like the crazy villain
comic-book stuff how do you like the way
the episodes and the story bounce back
and forth between those two things I do
think it's interesting I think it's
gonna make the writing a little bit
harder so we'll have to see how the
episodes end up turning out so here's
what's gonna happen next
new episode of Gotham next week be sure
to subscribe to get that heroes is
actually coming later this week that's
gonna be a Thursday show I will be doing
videos for it but it's not so Thursday
if there's any Batman videos that you
guys want me to do or like Batman V
Superman or anything like that just let
me know there's still a couple other
shows that haven't started either but
I'll try to mention like the DC stuff
during my DC related videos and the
Marvel stuff during my Marvel related
videos next week is actually the
beginning of agents of shield so while
you guys wait for all that stuff to drop
you can click here for the latest
trailer for the flash and arrow and you
can click here for all my other Batman V
Superman DC videos thank you so much for
watching everybody let's high five I'll
see you guys tomorrow
you